so first of all economic growth should
be prioritized over environmental
protections in future trade deals that's
the line emerging from a leaked document
seen by our deputy political editor as
we heard at the top of the pro programme
julia to you first of all on this the
government says nothing to see here they
say this isn't government policy they
say it's not being considered by
ministers but what's your reaction to
this leaked memo from civil servants
i i think it's very worrying indeed i
mean we've seen already the removal of
the paris commitment of one point aiming
for 1.5 degrees from the australia trade
deal and we should be using trade deals
to to encourage others and to pressurize
other countries to sign up and deliver
on these critical um paris and net zero
commitments
and we should also be using them to make
sure we're project protecting our own
industries
because we're expecting these very high
environmental standards rightly
and also expecting our own industries to
be on track for net zero we shouldn't be
importing goods where people haven't had
to to meet those standards and indeed
meet those sorts of costs
kel what do you think of this let me
just show you what the australian prime
minister scott morrison said he said in
trade agreements i deal with trade
issues and climate agreements i deal
with climate issues i mean some people
might say the main priority here is the
economy post-brexit post-covet
and any climate agreements can be made
separately
uh i'd have to push back on that for me
because i think the more we're learning
actually that all these different areas
of conversation and deals are actually
all intrinsically linked with climate
and i think if we're starting to
separate a trade deal and climate deal
uh it's actually quite ignorant because
you know climate affects trade uh and
climate affects money and climate
affects movement of goods and climate
affects everything so to actually
approach them as two very separate
things for me makes no sense and
actually as i think what was written in
the document just just go to show that
actually uh the uh economics of the deal
and maybe the partnership is putting as
a priority above the planet uh and
actually the agreements that are already
in in place so um it doesn't come as a
surprise and once again it is incredibly
infuriating and disheartening um just to
see these kind of uh memos whatever they
are being passed around if there's
nothing to to show me that they are
taking these things seriously yeah even
though the government will say that that
it's not policy but but julie what about
this issue that you said about imports
from countries that have less stringent
environmental standards is there some
way around that is there some way that
this country can put some kind of carbon
tariff on any of those imports so that
companies in this country that are
abiding by stricter rules don't lose out
well we know that that europe has been
considering border tax adjustments so
for example if you're importing steel
from a country which is um not
decarbonizing its power system so their
steel industry is getting cheaper um
cheaper electricity or or still able to
use coal for example um that steel gets
a gets um an additional tax put on it
sort of as it reaches the border so that
it competes on a level playing field
with the costs that industries in in
europe or in a country like the uk are
having to bear
the costs of supporting the
decarbonisation
and very quickly kell
of course just two weeks till cop do you
think this is a distraction ahead of
that
um i don't know if it's a distraction i
think it's actually quite uh as julie
kind of said uh quite worrying because
there are there are promises and pledges
and commitments that get made uh at
places like cop uh and knowing that
these sort of letters are going around
governments and that maybe these
promises that feels like lip service are
just that it doesn't give me much faith
that the deals and commitments we might
hear come out of copy in the next couple
of weeks
are going to mean anything and actually
if you look at the paris climate
agreement it's a case in point i think
all you have to do is dig a little bit
into the detail to realize not just the
uk but most countries aren't on track to
meet the goals that they have supposedly
committed to in a legally binding way so
when you look to see where is the
accountability um it's just very
frustrating and again it just doesn't
fill you with much faith of what's going
to come out of cop